the newly elected Congressman caught
lying about his background is talking
publicly about it for the first time in
a pair of interviews with conservative
news outlets in New York City
representative elect George Santos
defended his record but admitted he had
misstated his true biography most of the
lies were revealed in an investigation
by the New York Times earlier this month
Caitlin Huey Burns is more
a confession from the Republican
Congressman elect if I disappointed
anyone by resume embellishments I'm
sorry speaking out directly for the
first time about allegations he
fabricated his resume and life story
George Santos acknowledged to a New York
radio host that he told a string of lies
about his education and employment
history and I'm not going to make
excuses for this but a lot of people
overstayed in their resumes or
um twist a little bit or ingrangeate
themselves I'm not saying I'm not guilty
of that in another interview with the
New York Post Santos admitted he did not
have degrees from Baruch College and NYU
as he had claimed I didn't graduate from
any institution of Higher Learning I'm
embarrassed and sorry we do stupid
things in life he also admitted he never
worked directly for Goldman Sachs or
Citigroup despite frequently touting the
credential while campaigning when I
first started in my career at Citigroup
I was told oh you're a really smart guy
now Santos says a company he worked for
called link Bridge did business with
those Wall Street firms Santos also
addressed scrutiny around his claims of
Jewish Heritage on his campaign website
in a section now removed he recalled his
grandparents fleeing Jewish persecution
during World War II I am Catholic he
told the post because I learned my
maternal family had a Jewish background
I said I was Jewish and he said he lied
about owning 13 properties admitting he
lives with his sister but questions
about his finances remain including
seven hundred thousand dollars he
reported to have loaned his campaign a
claim that went unchecked in the radio
interview Monday the seven hundred
thousand dollars you put into the
election was that your money
that is the money of that I've paid
myself through my company the vulner
organizations understood
despite the admission Santos said he
won't be deterred from serving his full
term in Congress and said he intends to
deliver on the promises he made during
the campaign Trail he is slated to be
sworn into Congress next week Nate
Caitlin thank you